how do you feel about recent outbreaks of a summer
fever we view any outbreak of anti-semitism was
great correct American Legion is because of
the makeup of the organization to go to the
ideals of committed absolutely against great
discrimination of a prejudice I said before
that the Pharaoh who operates on the theory of
prejudice according to race or religion has a
mind that sunk in description he's generalizing
on something that cannot be generalized time so
the American Legion I can report the Raptors
Jews would hire and along any outrageous they
may or not the ISM anti-semitic any
other religious original prejudice
how do you feel about recent outbreaks of
the jalapeno we knew when he outbreak of
any kind of thing and what's very correct
immaculate you know it because the makeup
of the organization to go to the ideal again
range discrimination or a negative that before
that the Pharaoh operates on the theory of
prejudice according to race or religion as
a mind it's Duncan detection he's generalizing
on something that cannot be generalized so the
American Legion I can report the Raptors
Jews with horror and alarm any outbreak
they may or not be over anti-semitism
any other religious or racial prejudice
any outbreak of anti-semitism was no correct
immaculate you know as he touched the makeup
of the organization to go to the idea against
race discrimination erase president as that
before the federal rule operates on the
period prejudice according to race or
religion as a mine that sunk in description
is generalizing and something that cannot be
generalized for the American Legion I can
report the Raptors use would horror and
alarm any outrage of the neo-nazi agent and he
SEMATECH any other religious original prejudice